Glanz und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus
versunken zwischen Büchern auch im
optischen Sinne versuchen klein und
krümelig gegenüber die Bücherberg
[Gelächter]
ist doch doch doch ich knie auf der Yoga
die ich selber hier nie benutzen ich bin
ja gar kein Jogi ja ja aber damit nicht
so hart ist ein Knien und okay jetzt
kurze Frage warum sitzt du nicht ich
wüsste nicht wo also das ist ja ein Raum
in dem es keine Sitzgelegenheit gibt
genau wie viele Bücher hast du ich weiß
es nicht ich geh nicht zu den Menschen
deutlich weniger es liegt ja auch daran
dass sie aus Platzgründen immer im
großen Stil Bücher ausmisten
was also echt schwierig ist im Grunde
genommen kann man ja sagen guck mal ich
gucke jetzt gerade so auf die Wirtschaft
Bibliothek ja und so die ganzen Sachen
die so in den letzten 15 Jahren oder so
geschrieben sind und eigentlich könnte
man drei Viertel davon aussortieren
Bücher über die Finanzkrise und solche
Sachen teilweise jetzt wovon bekannten
Verfassern nur Standard Sachen und so
unterfragt man sich immer guckst du da
jemals wieder rein ist das nicht alles
veraltetes wissen würdest du nicht wenn
jetzt irgendeine Neuigkeit eine
finanzbanken passiert ich im Internet
schlau machen würdest du wirklich dieses
Buch noch mal mit den Rezepten von 2008
oder 2010 rausholen ne und eigentlich
könnte man natürlich wahnsinnig viel weg
tun weil wir leben ja in einer Zeit der
gegenwarts Schrumpfung so eins meiner
lieblingsbegriffe stammt von Hermann
Lübbe ja ja ein großer deutscher
Philosoph und von dem stammt das jetzt
ein ganz alter Mann falls noch lebt ich
meine lebt noch alles deutlich über 90
und daneben stand der Begriff gegenwarts
Schrumpfung er sagt dass die
Halbwertszeit von wissen
ja dass die immer kürzer wird also für
früher gab es so bestimmte Standard
Dinge in den Naturwissenschaften oder
wird worauf man sich in der Theologie
gerade geeinigt hatte die sollte dann
irgendwie Jahrzehnte oder Jahrhunderte
halten und heute ist das eigentlich so
dass die die Weisheiten von heute die
sind schon in zwei drei Jahren der
kälteste Kaffee der Welt das Interesse
auch in den Naturwissenschaften zum Teil
der Meinung zu hören Gentechnik und so
ja also man wird ja man ständig bedroht
damit dass das eigene Wissen stirbt ja
und dann quasi die Gegenwart zusammen
also die Gegenwart in der etwas gültig
ist wird immer kürzer
irre ich muss gerade an Jürgen
Schmidhuber denken der in dieser Woche
bei uns war den du auch kennst soll ich
lieb grüßen übrigens hat mich wahnsinnig
fasziniert ich weiß nicht wie es dir
gegen KI Pionier ja also die Tatsache
dass wir heute mit unserem Telefon
kommunizieren können dass du sagen
kannst hey Google zeig mir mal den Weg
zum Hauptbahnhof Bahnhof oder so das
geht auf Grundlagenforschung von Herrn
Schmidhuber und seinen Studenten an der
TU in München Anfang der 90er Jahre
zurück und der sagt das auch und ich
habe ihn zum Schluss gefragt ob er dir
dann von ausgeht dass es noch zu seinen
Lebzeiten ein künstliches Wesen geben
wird das intelligenter sein wird als er
selbst und er sagte ich gehe davon aus
wenn ich statistisch so alt werde wie es
im Moment die Statistiken eben hergeben
fand ich wirklich bemerkenswert und ich
ein bisschen frei in die Frage in was
intelligenter also wahrscheinlich nicht
Allround intelligenter ich glaube das
schwebt ihm so vor also das er sagt
irgendwie also das war so der Gedanke
der der ein irgendwie schüttelt und die
dann aber auch gleichzeitig fasziniert
und packte sagt es es liegt doch etwas
erhaben ist in dem Gedanken das ist
irgendwann evolutionär eine höhere
Entwicklungsform gibt als uns Menschen
das heißt dass wir noch lange nicht das
Ende der Evolution sind
und ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das so
erhaben ist oder eher beängstigend ist
man müsste für ihn ein neues Wort
erfinden weil es gibt ja das sind ja die
allermeisten Ethiker sie sind
anthropozentristen das heißt also wir
sollen den Klimawandel verhindern für
die Zukunft der Menschheit die ganze
Moral und Ethik ist darauf ausgerichtet
dass die Menschen noch möglichst lange
auf diesem Planeten leben können und so
der Mensch im Mittelpunkt dann gibt es
eine bestimmte Spezies das sind
biozentriker die denken nicht vor
Menschen aus sondern die Denken von der
Erde ja möchten dass die ganzen Tiere
und Pflanzen überleben und so und die
wünschen sich eigentlich dass der Mensch
baldmöglichst
der berühmteste Vertreter dieser
Richtung ne diese englische Allround
Wissenschaftler der damals diese gay ja
Hypothese die war so in den 80er 90ern
total nichts mit mit homo sexuell zu tun
auch die die Kreidefelsen ja haben ein
Leben ja und und und das die torfm Moore
Leben und so weiter und so weiter genau
aber Schmidhuber wäre eine dritte
Kategorie ist ein technozentrisch ja das
heißt das das faszinierendste für ihn
sind Menschen findet ja nicht besonders
faszinierend die Erde interessiert ihn
eigentlich auch nicht wir träumt ja
immer vom großen Aufbruch in die Sterne
in die unendlichen Weiten Erde ist ja
nicht viel zu klein und krümelig sondern
eigentlich die die Faszination daran
dass die Technik die der Mensch erfindet
über ihn hinaus Weg wächst und dann
eigenständig das Werk des Menschen ja
Eroberung von allem genau fortsetzt und
das fasziniert ihn so wie den
biozentriker und die Wale und und den
anthropozentriker der
diese schwierige Liebe zur Spezies
menschpflege und alles möchte damit sie
bloß erhalten bleibt genau ich ich finde
ein Gespräch mit Jürgen Schmidhuber auf
eine herrliche Art erfrischend weil es
so ganz anders ist als als das was
häufig bei uns so passiert ne diese ich
finde man kann ja zurecht ganz vieles
anmerken man kann Angst haben vor dieser
künstlichen Intelligenz man kann sagen
das bedroht uns man kann sagen das auch
schwierig für die Demokratie weil
plötzlich meinungsmolekulation in einem
Ausmaß möglich ist wie es noch nie in
der Geschichte der Menschheit der Fall
war wenn man ihn aber wiederum hört dann
kriegt man noch mal ganz anderen Blick
darauf ja also für ihn ist das einfach
nur eine Fülle an Möglichkeiten und der
sagt sowas wie Chat GPT das ist gerade
erst mal der Anfang das ist alles hinter
einer Scheibe hinter einem Monitor aber
dann geht es darum dass zu übertragen 3D
ja was was kann ein Kind was passiert im
Kopf damit ein Kind laufen kann damit es
Fußball spielen kann und so weiter
das hat er in der Sendung auch ein
bisschen demonstriert das war absolut
sensationell aber Richard Gegenwart
Schrumpfung ja also sozusagen die Idee
alte Gewissheiten gelten nicht mehr
funktioniert nicht mehr ja ich meine das
ist doch die perfekte Brücke zu dem
Thema aber dass ich mit dir reden wollte
der Aufstieg der AFD ja da kommt dieser
afd-kandidat in Thüringen Landrat Robert
Sesselmann und der mit 52,8 % in Kreis
Sonneberg gewinnt und alles dreht
plötzlich durch ein Landrat von
Landkreisen in Deutschland ein einziger
der der zwei kleinste Land in
Deutschland mit ich glaube etwas weniger
als 60.000 Menschen ja 57
000 Menschen so und alles dreht durch
und was machst du ich drehe nicht durch
weil ich wunder Dich darüber
erst zu spät also ich hätte irgendwie
meinem unbewussten irgendwie gedacht
dass die AFD schon längst Landräte
stellt ja ja also ich meine bei denen
wahnsinnig kleinen Landkreisen gerade da
in Thüringen und so und dann bei den
Werten die die AFD übermalen und erst
recht jetzt bei Umfragen bekommt ist das
jetzt keine ganz große Sensation oder
Überraschung aber dann eben auch doch ne
weil viele das Gefühl haben das ist
jetzt so ein Dammbruch so ein so ein
Tabubruch und die Frage die ich mit dir
mal diskutieren wollte ist es das erste
Frage die zweite Frage nach dem Umgang
mit der AFD dritte Frage die die
Reaktion sozusagen der der anderen
Parteien ich hast du das Gefühl dass wir
angemessen auf diese politische Kraft
die es normal ist reagieren also wenn
wir angemessen darauf reagieren würden
dann würde sie nicht stark und stärker
werden
also wenn wir taktisch klug wären und
wenn wir alles dafür tun würden und zu
verhindern dass ihr AFD diesen Aufstieg
hat dann hätte man offensichtlich alles
anders machen müssen als man es bisher
gemacht hat denn bisher spielt alles der
AFD in die Karten und wenn sie über
Umfragen jetzt 20 % kriegt dann glaube
ich immer kriegt sie noch deutlich
bessere Wahlergebnisse weil nach wie vor
relativ viele Leute die die AFD wählen
das in Umfragen nicht so gern bekannt
geben
das hat ja was Anrüchiges häufig und
wenn man dann angerufen wird von so
Meinungsforschungsinstitut dann ist das
häufig so das aus gerade afd-wähler da
nicht so
sendungsbewusst heraus Posaunen was sie
wählen ich glaube also dass das
Potenzial der AFD noch deutlich höher
sein könnte als nur diese ominösen 20%
was glaubst du was wird da passieren
nicht ich spreche mit Leuten die mir
sagen das ist der Anfang da das geht
gerade erst richtig los ja das glaube
ich auch das glaube ich auch ja also das
glaube ich auch so lange die Partei sich
nicht in irgendeiner Form von
Regierungsverantwortung selbst
entzaubert glaube ich dass die Anzahl
der unzufriedenenden mit den etablierten
Parteien die ja die AFD in einem sehr
geschickt geschafft so Altparteien nennt
ja
dass das so weitergeht wird weil sie
profitiert ja von allem also ob sich die
Regierung über die Heizung Zank
migrationsgesetze eigentlich kann fast
gar nichts passieren Corona ja wo letzt
lich auch wahrscheinlich Ukraine Krieg
also wenn jedem Thema fängt die AFD
diejenigen ab die nicht eins zu eins
davor mit dem regierungs- sind und ich
hatte ja schon mal so von paar Wochen
gesagt die politische Topographie die
ist nicht einfach nur ein rechts und
links sortiert da gibt's noch ein
bisschen was davon übrig geblieben ist
sondern vor allen Dingen in angepasst
und nicht angepasst
ja also angepasst ist das was die Mitte
ist oder sein soll ob es nun eine
behauptete oder wirklich quantitative
Mitte ist was ich auch in den Leitmedien
so wiedergespiegelt findet und
diejenigen die sagen ich sehe aber ganz
anders
und die Leute die das irgendwie ganz
anders sehen das ist vielleicht
mutmaßlichen Drittel der Bevölkerung und
das ist das
Wachstumspotenzial der AFD die sagen ja
es gibt bestimmte Positionen die sind
unter repräsentiert die kommen nicht vor
unsere Sorgen kommen nicht vor und die
AFD greift das alles ab es ist ja ein
Kessel Buntes ne ich hatte unlängst ja
mal gesagt besteht aus Teilen die
eigentlich gar nicht zusammenpassen
richtig ne aber als diejenigen sagen wir
sind anders als die anderen funktioniert
das Spiel ziemlich gut das ist irre ich
meine ich immer mit Alexander gauland
vor vor Jahren mal darüber gesprochen
von Alexander gauland gibt es ein
wirklich guten Satz und ich glaube da
war sogar noch in der CDU und der Satz
lautet und Timo ist kein Programm
aber offenbar ist ein Programm solange
man in der Opposition ist genau ja
spätestens wenn man ihn Verantwortung
kommt ist das ziemlich schwierig jetzt
mache ich mir ehrlich gesagt um den
Landkreis Sonneberg nicht so die Riesen
sorgen
ich war muss ich überlegen wofür ist ein
Landrat überhaupt zuständig was fällt
überhaupt in dessen Kompetenz was was
könnte der schlimmsten Falls ja in
Sonneberg überhaupt irgendwie anrichten
und ich meine der Landrat ist zuständig
für Schulen Straßen Schwimmbäder und
öffentlichen Nahverkehr gehört das sind
so seine Hauptsorgen ja was kann man
machen rechtsextremistische Schwimmbäder
in denen Migranten keinen Zugang haben
oder die Schuhe sind aus wesselschule
umbenennen oder so ich meine die
Thüringer AFD ja ist äh neben der
sächsischen die die die rechteste ja und
da da spielen Figuren wie Stefan
Brandner und Björn hocken starke Rolle
aber selbst wenn ich deren bester Kumpel
bin und ich bin Landrat also was kann da
schlimmes möglich passieren das wird
mich mal interessieren was glaubst Du ja
ich sehe das exakt so wie du ich mein
Thema ist ein anderes Richard ich meine
der Mann hat plakatiert unter anderem
Verbrenner retten
den Verbrenner retten aber das in
Wahrheit bestenfalls zuständig für die
Freiwillige Feuerwehr eben also du
kannst den Verbrenner gar nicht retten
das wird ganz woanders entschieden es
wird noch nicht mal wirklich in Berlin
entschieden könnte wahrscheinlich
und in Wahrheit sogar in China ja da wo
die AFD gar nichts zu Hause ist nämlich
irgendwo im Bösen Ausland das heißt wenn
jemand den Sonneberg plakatiert
Verbrenner retten ist das das ist
eigentlich real Satire ja ich weiß das
gar nicht die Stadt hätte die Stadt also
es gibt eine Stadt Sonneberg ne und ein
Landkreis hätte die Stadt jetzt
sozusagen die Möglichkeit zu sagen wir
bauen auf unserem Stadtgebiet oder in
unserem Landkreis
keine Elektro Aufladestation für Autos
könnte man sowas machen
ich meine ich will nicht sagen dass da
mit der Frau Benner gerettet ist auch
schön wie so ein kleines geiles Dorf
irgendwann gibt es nur noch
batteriebetriebene Elektroautos bis auf
Sonneberg
die können paar bestimmte Dinge
natürlich kann er die entscheiden also
zum Beispiel Migrationspolitik ne die
Frage ob es zum Beispiel Geld oder
Sachleistungen gibt die kann er glaube
ich tatsächlich entscheiden okay da kann
er sagen was auf das machen wir so oder
so und das ist natürlich dann schon so
ein trägerpunkt aber wenn du plakatierst
Verbrenner retten ist das in Wahrheit
ehrlich gesagt komplett Leute veräppeln
weil das kannst du dir gerne wünschen
Verbrenner zu retten aber du
entscheidest das nicht schlicht und
ergreifend und so zu tun als würde sich
das mit dir ändern ist natürlich ein
Witz das funktioniert nicht aber noch
mal was passiert da gerade ich meine
wenn man sich das mal anschaut und vor
einigen Tagen
mir mal angesehen wie es in Thüringen
und Sachsen so prinzipiell aussieht mit
Blick auf Landtagswahlen ne also wenn
das so weitergeht kann ja eine Situation
eintreten dass der Osten na sagen wir
quasi unregierbar wird ja also Beispiel
Thüringen so unregierbar weil alle
anderen Parteien sagen wir koalieren
nicht mehr in der AFD so und nicht dann
keine Mehrheit gegen die AFD mehr
richtig ich dekliniere dir mal das
Beispiel ja Thüringen also ohne AFD oder
linke geht in Thüringen eigentlich
nichts ja gab es immer im April eine
Befragung da war die AFD bei 28 %. so
irgendwo da sind die immer noch weit vor
der Linken irgendwo 2022% CDU auch um
die 20 SPD 11 Grünewald abgeschlagen
sechs FDP 5 und so weiter das heißt
nicht mal ein Vierer Bündnis aus CDU SPD
Grünen und FDP hätte eine Mehrheit das
wenn die CDU weitersagt weder mit der
Linkspartei und noch mit der AFD dann
könnte genau diese Situation eintreten
ich glaube dass man im Zweifelsfall mit
würde weil ramellos ungefähr so links
wie Kretschmann grün ja aber das ist der
fällt jetzt nicht dadurch
austreten will oder dass er
riesige verstaatlichungsprogramme
durchführen will Wohneigentum in
Genossenschaftswesen übernimmt und so
weiter also ich nehme an im Zweifel zwei
würden die CDU mit der Linkspartei
koalieren und das würde der AFD wieder
bedeuten die sitzen alle Altparteien in
einem einzigen Boot ja wir gegen die ja
und können eine solche Koalition würde
ihn unglaublich nützen für den nutzen
weil sie könnten wieder sagen guck mal
wie sie euch belogen haben sie haben
noch immer gesagt auf gar keinen Fall
mit der Linkspartei und zack um das
puren macht der halswillen machen sie es
doch ja Sachsen in Sachsen lag zuletzt
im Februar bzw mich jetzt auf eine
Umfrage aus dem Februar lagen im Februar
CDU und AFD mit ungefähr 30 % gleich
auch
grüne bei 10 SPD auch ungefähr bei 10
linke auch ungefähr bei 10 die FDP war
damals mit 4% gar nicht im Landtag das
heißt für die bisherige Koalition von
CDU SPD und Grünen als gerade noch
gereicht ja aber problem 1 zwischen
schwarz-rot und grün gibt es ständig
Ärger weil da auch so neuer Kulturkampf
plötzlich ausgebrochen ist Friedrich
Merz sagt die Grünen sind auf gar keinen
Fall mehr irgendwie einer gottgegebener
Koalitionspartner das heißt man will
sich da irgendwie von verabschieden und
Problem zwei selbst wenn die FDP doch
noch über die 5% kommt reicht es nicht
für Schwarz Rot Gelb allein ja und wenn
die AFD dann noch mal zulegt bräuchte
man quasi schon ein Vierer Bündnis zum
Regieren das klingt jetzt alles ein
bisschen kompliziert und ist viel aber
wenn es dir mal auf so einem Diagramm
anschaust dann merkst Du plötzlich da
kann eine Situation eintreten in der du
nicht mehr richtig gut Politik machen
kannst
davon hat am Ende keiner mehr was das
ist richtig und dann ist die Frage wohin
führt sozusagen diese ausschließeritis
und daraus resultiert die Frage wie
umgehen mit der AFD und da habe ich
jetzt eine konkrete Frage an dich
Richard was ich immer beobachte ist die
Reflexe sind immer harte Kante wir
müssen uns abgrenzen immer dieser wie
soll man sagen diese diese diese diese
dieser moralische Furor der sofort
durchkommt ich findest du denen also ich
man kann das von zwei Seiten betrachten
wenn ich das jetzt abwägen ne wenn man
sagt 'ne Partei die von der einige
führungspolitiker und ein nicht
unerheblicher Teil der Wähler den
Nationalsozialismus relativ gut findet
oder fand oder zumindestens harmlos und
sich innerlich davon nicht verabschiedet
hat eine solche Partei wenn die in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland in eine
Regierungsbeteiligung kommt dann ist das
ein riesiges Problem so diesen Gedanken
kann ich erstmal nachvollziehen so
ähnlicher Heimatbaum und längst auch
geäußert ja es kann doch nicht sein dass
so viel Jahre nach dem Holocaust und im
Zweiten Weltkrieg und so weiter Leute
die die Nazi vorbrechen leugnen
beschönigen oder klammheimlich sogar gut
finden dass solche Leute in die
Regierungsverantwortung kommen jetzt
muss man einen Links dazu sagen das hat
zumindestens hat sie ja auch schon mal
im Parlamenten gegeben die NPD war
glaube ich in vier Länderparlamenten in
den 60er Jahren also das ist das
Gespenst war nie tot es kommt jetzt aber
irgendwo wieder und diese Haltung ist
erstmal von moralischen Perspektive
nachvollziehbar auf der anderen Seite
muss ich sagen wenn ich die AFD
weiterhin so konsequent Ausgrenze und
wenn ich sage die sind nichts tragbar
und mit denen will ich überhaupt nichts
zu tun haben und dieses ausgrenzen
findet dann statt dass alle anderen
Parteien sich einig sind gegen diese
eine Partei dann hat das so mit
demokratischen schwierigen auch nicht
mehr so viel zu tun ja ihr seid zwar
gewählt und ihr habt ja hier 20% 30
Prozent aber diesen Wähler Willen nehmen
wir nicht ernst wir schließen euch
grundsätzlich von allem aus ist auch ein
Problem und dann muss man in der
Abwägung dieser beiden Fragen sich doch
die Frage stellen was würde die AFD am
stärksten entzaubern dass man radikal
nichts mit ihr zu tun haben will und sie
weiterhin als Sammelbecken der
unzufriedenen immer stärker und stärker
wird oder dass sie irgendwo in eine
Verantwortung Gerät jetzt nicht auf dem
auf Bundesebene aber irgendwo anders in
Verantwortung Gerät und dann so eine
schöne Karriere hinlegen kann wie die
Freiheitlichen in Österreich mit Haider
und so ein Strache also sehen dass es
sich auch um zum Teil unfähige Politiker
handelt dass viele dieser Politiker
korrupt sind dass sie mit praktischen
Fragen überfordert sind und und und denn
alles das würde sich erweisen wenn die
AFD tatsächlich in diese Verantwortung
käme das heißt die Partei funktioniert
ja nur als Protest und
Oppositionsparteien die würde ich als
Regierungspartei gar nicht funktioniert
[Musik]
die Frage des Umgangs Richard ich ich
habe das Thema selber ständig ja also
die Frage lädt man afd-politiker in eine
Sendung ein ich musste ehrlich sagen ich
verstehe nicht warum man das immer
wieder erklären muss man muss
selbstverständlich man muss auf das
mitgekriegt hast werden den
klimapolitischen Sprecher an Portrait
bei uns in der Sendung vor einiger Zeit
haben wir auch glaube ich drüber
gesprochen und ich ich fand es total
interessant einfach mal zu hören welche
klimapolitischen Ansichten die AFD hat
da war tatsächlich nicht so richtig viel
energiepolitisch klimapolitisch das war
ein sehr interessanter Austausch habe
ich wirklich viel gelernt und und der
Country hat das auch um sehr sportlich
alles genommen ja hat sich auch
hinterher nicht in irgendeiner Weise
eben unfair verhalten oder hat dann
sozusagen wieder das dass das dass die
die die die böse Geschichte erzählt da
kommt also das öffentlich rechtliche
Fernsehen und legt mich rein oder aufs
Kreuz und stellt mich bloß und dann
sagte ganz offen ich war da an dem ein
diesem Punkt nicht so richtig gut
vorbereitet das fand ich an sehr
sportlichen guten Austausch und ich
finde so muss es auch sein und was ich
feststelle ist und da ist er mein Thema
ich erlebe das so viele Leute
mittlerweile so ein bisschen unsicher
werden ich erlebe Leute ist aus der
sogenannten bürgerlichen Mitte die sagen
na ja es läuft vieles wirklich gut und
dann kommt noch diese ganze Geschichte
mit der Heizung und wir kriegen die
Migration nicht in Griff und so weiter
wir vielleicht sind die doch nicht so
schlimm vielleicht kann man die doch mal
wählen und dann denke ich immer dann ist
es doch unser Job diese Leute einzuladen
mit den Harz zu diskutieren und zu sagen
was sind eure Konzepte also musst du
überlegen was bedeutet version was ist
euer Konzept im Klima was ist euer Thema
Energie wie haltet ihr es mit Russland
zum Beispiel Sonneberg sehr interessant
Sonneberg der Landkreis über den wir
gerade sprechen 57 000 Einwohner die
suchen händeringend unterschreiben Sie
auf Ihre Homepage Fachkräfte das heißt
die wählst du den afd-landrat brauchst
aber ganz dringend Zuwanderung weil
deine Firmen reihenweise pleite gehen
und den Umfragen sagen in Sonneberg die
größte Bedrohung für unseren Wohlstand
ist Fachkräftemangel ist doch verrückt
und das muss man doch machen so
funktioniert wenn der afd-landrat Leute
aus anderen Kulturkreisen nach Sonneberg
holt weil er woanders keine
Arbeitskräfte kriegt gegen den gibt es
keine Opposition von wem soll die kommen
richtig ja das heißt nur der kann das
machen ich meine das habe ich ja auch
schon mal gesagt das wäre doch hier in
der Politiker
genauso ironisch läuft das ich sage
immer die SPD hat all die Dinge gemacht
in der Regierungsverantwortung in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik die gegen
sie als Opposition nicht durchsetzbar
gewesen
und so weiter und so weiter ja also man
muss eigentlich immer antizyklisch
wählen
und ich glaube dass nur ein afd-landrat
eine Migrationspolitik für Sonneberg
machen kann
bei jeder andere Landrat würde von der
afd-opposition für das gleiche zerfetzt
genau aber deine schon also allein im
Medien demokratisch musst du die AFD
einladen also eine Partei die im
Augenblick etwa 20% des Volks Willens
repräsentiert die kann nicht vom
öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen die
Luft behandelt werden und sagen die
kommen bei uns nicht vor ja finde ich
auch ja also es gibt es gibt die Pflicht
dass die dass die vertreten werden ja
und dass man natürlich kann man sie dann
auseinandernehmen und auf Herz und
Nieren klopfen und so weiter alles klar
aber du kannst nicht so tun als wären
die irgendwie nicht da dann
repräsentierst du ja schon mal dieses
20% der Bevölkerung nicht mehr und das
kann der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk
ich mache das zweite ist ja auch diese
moralische Überlegenheit mit Nazis
diskutiert ich nicht was auch immer so
ein bisschen mit klingt wie auch die
Leute die mit den sympathisieren die Sie
wählen sind alles rechtsradikale ich
habe das Gefühl was ich würde mich deine
Meinung interessieren Richard gerade
auch in Ostdeutschland gibt es bei
vielen Leuten mittlerweile einen eine
echte Wut darüber dass ich ständig
Kollektiv zu rechtsradikalen erklärt
werden ja also die sind ja schon zu
einem erklärt worden ne also am Anfang
sind sie also ich ich habe diese
Geschichte sehr lebhaft vor Augen also
die Arroganz des Westens gegenüber den
Menschen in Ostdeutschland ja das ist
eine eine Fehlleistung sondern gleichen
gewesen wir kamen uns als Sieger umso
toller vor ja je mehr wir alle Leute im
Osten wir haben deren Biografien
zusammengestrichen werden gesagt ja ihr
habt doch 40 Jahre einem Unrechtsstaat
geliebt so das haben wir auch Leuten
erzählt die erst 18 waren die also noch
keine 40 Jahre Zeit dazu hatten das
stimmt wir haben uns nie die Frage
gestellt was hätte denn der ganz normale
Mensch bei uns wenn eine DDR groß
geworden wäre es hätte den gemacht wenn
wir alle Widerstandskämpfer gewesen ja
hätten wir dieses System gestürzt schon
vom ersten Tag an also was für ein
verqueres chirurgische Selbstbild haben
wir die meisten Menschen in jeder
Gesellschaft sind Mitläufer und das ist
hier in der Gesellschaft nicht anders
als es in der Gesellschaft der DDR war
dann haben in der DDR vor einigen die
Leute nachher riesenkarrieren gemacht
die nicht als Widerstandskämpfer
aufgefallen sind Angela Merkel Joachim
Gauck ich meine das sozusagen auch noch
der Widerstand den es ja tatsächlich
gegeben hat ja und auch der Mut dass der
auch gar nicht nachher groß belohnt
worden ist dass wir dann auch die die
gesamte Wirtschaft in der DDR so
komplett für unfähig erklärt hätten als
hätten ausnahmslos Idioten dort
gearbeitet als wären sie also alle
politische Idioten gewesen
wirtschaftliche Idioten gewesen die von
morgens bis abends nichts anderes zu tun
gehabt haben als ihre Nachbarn
zugespitzen das war das Bild was wir da
drin hat wir haben bis heute einen
ostbeauftragten na das ist der der für
die Indianerreservate im Osten zuständig
ist ja also haben wir selber ein
Indianer genommen ja und ich erkläre es
jetzt für diese Reservate zuständig oder
Native American Reservate vorsichtige
auszudrücken sowas kann man nicht machen
also dann hätte man gleichzeitig ein
vespaauftragten machen müssen also
beauftragte soll ja irgendwie in
irgendeiner Form die Belange des Ostens
in den Westen tragen aber es wäre doch
schön die Belange des Westens auf die
gleiche Art in den Osten zu tragen wir
sind anders ja man kennst du ne ja ich
habe es leider nicht gelesen aber das
ist ein Bestseller und ich freue mich
darauf dieses Thema Erfolg hat ja
absolut ne der Osten eine westdeutsche
Erfindung es ist ein ein großartiges
Buch irgendwie indem er genau ähm
darüber schreibt und sagt irgendwie ich
wollte eigentlich keins der üblichen
Bücher darüber schreiben wie schlimm im
Osten alles ist weil eigentlich ist eben
nicht der Osten sein Thema sondern und
das entscheidend der Westen ja und sagt
es geht eben um diesen eklatanten Mangel
an Repräsentation auch an Kenntnis der
Geschichte und so weiter und um die Art
und Weise wie wir damit umgehen ja auch
wenn man sich Anteile an Führungsebenen
anschaut und so weiter abseits der
Politik zwei bis vier Prozent ja also
der OST ist nach wie vor und nicht
wirklich
repräsentiert also ich kann mich in
meinem eigenen Ideen eine westdeutsche
Erfindung der stimmt ja und ich kann
mich wunderbar daran erinnern so aus
meinem Horizon ich war Mitte 20 als die
Mauer fiel und wenn ich mir angucke wie
damals die Professoren von meiner und
von vielen anderen Universitäten dann an
die Universitäten in den Osten gegangen
sind Kommissionen gegründet haben und
darüber befunden haben welcher Professor
jetzt im Amt bleiben darf und welcher
nicht
das heißt das durften die nicht selber
machen was ja auch naheliegend gewesen
wäre zu sagen das war immer so ein
tausendprozentiger und der war hier und
ganz schlimm und ein halber Stalin ist
und so weiter nein das haben Leute aus
dem Westen gemacht die da nichts wussten
und nichts kannten die haben sich dann
zu Richtern aufgeschwungen was haben sie
gemacht möglichst viele Leute die im
Osten im akademischen Betrieb waren
entlassen und ihre eigenen Assistenten
dort installiert also das ist eine
Haltung gewesen wie das Kolonialreiche
machen ja man hat ein anderes Gebiet
erobert und jetzt setzt man seine
eigenen Leute da rein und das was hier
in den Unis gelaufen ist ist natürlich
auch bei vielen Firmen so gelaufen und
ich meine dieses diese merkwürdige
gefühlswart nein dass die Menschen im
Osten gehabt haben also jetzt haben Sie
die Möglichkeit zu mir Wohlstand zu
kommen jetzt haben Sie die Möglichkeit
freier über politische Dinge reden zu
können und so weiter und jetzt werden
sie aber von Anfang an als Bürger
zweiter Klasse integriert
und ich glaube dass dieses Gefühl auch
so lange nach der Wiedervereinigung
immer noch sehr sehr tief sitzt also
dieses Thema Ost-West ist ja nicht weg
also damals hätte man doch gedacht da
nach der Wiedervereinigung 90 ja in 30
Jahren reden wir darüber nicht mehr ja
reden über diese Dinge noch ziemlich
stark nach 30 Jahren absolut und ich
hätte es auch so nicht für möglich
gehalten Oschmann weist auf etwas sehr
Interessantes hin und sagt ihm den
Zusammenhang auch alles was ich da sage
ist nichts neues das ist alles über
Jahre schon gesagt worden das ist viel
besser auch schon dokumentiert und
recherchiert worden aber ich sag's
trotzdem noch mal im Osten sind die
Gehälter im Schnitt 22,5% geringer als
im Westen das ist so eine Zahl die man
kennt was mir nicht bewusst war war in
der Auto und IT-Branche
und darüber reden wir gerade ne ich
meine in Sachsen hat eine ziemlich gut
gehende Wirtschaft und gerade im Bereich
Automobil und jetzt Magdeburg auch Intel
IT und so weiter
40% geringerer Lohn
Textilbranche sogar 69% und Oschmann
sagt gleichzeitig fordert der Westen
dass ich der Osten jetzt endlich mal
normalisieren soll jetzt werdet endlich
mal normal genau hat er natürlich einen
Punkt ist ist sehr zugespitzt aber hatte
einen Punkt und ich ich habe vom paar
Wochen mit Sarah pago mal gesprochen das
brillante Frau von Think Tanke in Berlin
Politikwissenschaftlerin Russland
Expertin eigentlich und kommt aus
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
und die Atmas und paar Dinge in ein
Kontext gestellt und das das fand ich
hochinteressant die sagte Russland
spielt dabei eine große Rolle und auch
das ist etwas was wir nicht verstanden
haben wenn wir über den Osten sprechen
sie sagt Russland ist Teil der
ostdeutschen Identität das ist erstmal
unser Satz aber wenn du dann mal rein
gehst dann erklärt sie dir das mal
historisch und das ist spannend sie sagt
vor dem Zweiten Weltkrieg war ja
Deutschland quasi weltpolitisch weder
dem Westen noch dem Osten groß
zugeordnet ne da waren wir quasi so
dazwischen ja wird wir fühlten uns als
die größten überhaupt also wir waren
dazwischen wir waren was völlig eigenes
richtig und wir hatten Vorurteile gegen
beide Richtungen Osten wie gegen den
Westen genau also Amerika hatte kein
gutes Image genau und dann sagt sie ist
total interessant mit der Teilung des
Landes also nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
dann also im besetzten nachkrieg
Deutschland hat sich die deutsche
Bevölkerung das kann man sich total gut
vorstellen erst fremdbestimmt gefühlt
das dann so ein Anti-Amerikanismus
entstanden genau das was du gerade
beschreibst und sie sagt das ist kein
grundsätzlich ostdeutsches Phänomen
ursprünglich gewesen aber dann kommt im
Westen dieser steigende Lebensstandard
und dann verschwindet sozusagen dieser
Anti-Amerikanismus in der Bundesrepublik
immer mehr weil man merkt auch okay die
Amis sind gekommen die haben das
übernommen der die Marktwirtschaft der
Kapitalismus also die Besatzer von
ehemals werden immer mehr als Befreier
quasi gegenüber nimmt komplett die
amerikanische Kultur in amerikanische
Musik ja genau oder die
angloamerikanische Musik die Mode ne
also mit Jeans und und Beatles und
Stones und was weiß ich was und so
weiter beginnt
die Westintegration richtig richtig und
sie sagt in der DDR ganz anders sie sagt
zu Unzufriedenheit mit dem eigenen
Regime kommen dann auch noch die
Abneigung gegenüber diesem fremden
Westen und das hat sich über die Jahre
immer weiter manifestiert aufgebaut in
Form von Misstrauen in Politik
Institutionen Medien und das hat Folgen
bis heute und sie sagt dieser Ukraine
kriegt zum Beispiel der wird jetzt von
den ostdeutschen genau aus dieser
Geschichte heraus deswegen ist das so
spannend in Wahrheit als Konflikt nicht
zwischen Putin und Ukraine wahrgenommen
sondern zwischen Ost und West und dass
der Grund warum man sich heraushalten
möchte das hat damit zu tun das ist
diese Identifikation mit dem Westen aus
diesen historischen Gründen nicht gibt
man fühlt sich weder zu dem einen noch
zu dem anderen richtig hingezogen
man kann das auch anders ausdrücken also
du hast das indirekt gesagt ja in der in
der DDR ist das alte Deutschland
lebendig geblieben also die
Bundesrepublik hat eine enorme
kulturelle Transformation durchgemacht
richtig von diesem Deutschland das mit
dem Osten und mit dem Westen nichts zu
tun haben will ja dass auch Krieg
geführt hat zwei Weltkriege gegen den
Osten und den Westen die also beide
Feindbilder waren Frankreich als der
große Erbfeind auf der einen Seite ja
Russland als der der Lebensraum in dem
slawische Orden Leben den man für die
deutschen erobern will also Deutschland
war umgeben von von Völkern auf die man
heruntergeguckt hat und gegen die man
massiv etwas hatte und vieles von dem
was das alte Deutschland so kulturell
ausgemacht hat ich meine jetzt gar nicht
diese aggressive Seite ist in der DDR
erhalten geblieben erhalten geblieben
ist wenn ich so wir haben ja schon über
Brandenburg gesprochen wenn du auch nur
ein kleines Stück aus Berlin raus fährst
dann hast du plötzlich das Gefühl auch
in einer anderen Zeit zu leben also wie
die Gastronomie aussieht wie Leute damit
einander reden also diese diese
Freundlichkeit die du in den
Touristenzentren in Berlin hast die ist
da nicht mehr in der gleichen Art und
Weise sondern ist das eher wieder so wie
es wo ich aufgewachsen bin im Bergischen
Land in den 60er 70er Jahren war
es du hast irgendwie so Stück für Stück
das Gefühl du reist immer tiefer in die
deutsche Vergangenheit und das hat nicht
nur etwas Negatives das ist das nicht
einfach belastet mit Rippen reich oder
so sondern da hast du das Gefühl hier
ist Deutschland noch am deutsches sie
hat sich sehr viel nicht verändert hier
ist noch sehr viele so wie es im
Kaiserreich war im Dritten Reich in der
DDR war und jetzt in der Bundesrepublik
in der Verein ist so ein bisschen das
Gefühl ist natürlich nicht überall die
Zeit stehen geblieben das erste was Sie
auffällt sind diese Glitzer über in
jedem brandenburgischen
mecklenburgischen Dorf ist mit welchen
Subventionen oder so auch immer das
davon neu gedenken
so so plastikartig leuchtende Lego
Dächer aber es gibt viele andere Dinge
wo du auch wenn man mit den Menschen und
so ein bisschen das Gefühl hat man man
reist eigentlich zurück in die
Vergangenheit während die Bundesrepublik
eine Transformation gemacht hat von
Deutschland zu Westen genau ja also
Westen heißt ja eigentlich
angloamerikanisch nicht so sehr
französisch vielleicht noch ein bisschen
auch italienisch Lebensweise draußen
sitzen abends und Pizza essen und so
aber eigentlich ist die ganz große
Prägung gewesen die angloamerikanische
dass man das deutsche da gar nicht mehr
rausfiltern könnte ihr müsst es sowieso
ein Goldsucher mit dem Sieb müsste so
lange machen ein bisschen paar kleine
deutsche Klümpchen noch findest und das
ist im Osten ganz anders geblieben das
ist also und dann der Stolz nach der
Vereinigung das was es für den Osten
bedeutet hat ist wir sind wieder Werbung
dieses kleine sondern wir sind wieder
Teil des großen Deutschland und
vielleicht haben auch viele erwartet
dass es wieder ein großes Deutschland
mit Betonung auf Deutschland wird
na und ich glaube dass das sehr stark in
den Köpfen vieler Menschen sind die das
in keiner Partei wiederfinden sondern
nur in der AFD ich finde ich also für
mich gibt es sozusagen einen oder zwei
zentrale Begriffe über die man da glaube
ich mal nachdenken muss und wie ist das
auch klar geworden ich würde über einen
letzten sondern mehrfach in Bulgarien
unterwegs
wir haben jetzt auch gerade in Moldau
gedreht haben wir schon drüber
gesprochen
die die dann sagen diese Landschaften
das kulturelle die Gastronomie der
demografische Faktor ja also viele Leute
abgewandert das auch in Thüringen ein
riesige Tiere Thüringen hat einen
wahnsinns Aderlass erlebt ne nach der
Wiedervereinigung das sind Millionen
Menschen einfach weg die sind nicht mehr
da über Bulgarien haben in dem
Zusammenhang schon mal gesprochen ja die
waren kurz davor 9 Millionen zu werden
sind jetzt irgendwann im Bereich von
fünf das heißt da verändern sich Dinge
da verändern sich gesellschaftschaften
da bleiben sozusagen Menschen zurück für
die es sich nicht mehr lohnt irgendwo im
weiß ich nicht in Deutschland oder in
Amerika ein neues Leben anzufangen und
so weiter weil sie vielleicht an einem
ganz anderen Punkt ihres Lebens stehen
und so weiter weil sie Familie haben
weil sie nicht mehr so beweglich sind so
all das macht etwas aber die Frage ist
immer sind die Leute Anti sind sie
sozusagen von Grund auf gegen den Westen
oder sind sie und das ist immer mein
Gefühl
skeptisch die hat immer das Gefühl wenn
Du 40 Jahre so lebst wenn du diese
Distanz versuchst zu halten wie wir sie
gerade besprochen haben ja zu den
Amerikanern aber auch zu den Russen die
ja es gab ja auch darauf weist Sarah
pagung hin es ist ein völliger Irrglaube
zu denken dass das in in Ostdeutschland
alle totale russenfans totaler quatschen
genau hochambivalent es gibt sozusagen
die ältere Generation von Menschen wie
Matthias Platzeck und anderen die sagen
wir müssen uns mit denen irgendwie
verständigen aber provozieren sie nicht
weil die sind gefährlich eine jüngere
Generation wie Manuela Schwesig oder
oder Michael Kretschmer oder andere die
haben die gefährlichen Russen nicht
erlebt die haben den Betrunkenen jetzt
eben gesehen die haben gesehen da
torkelt sozusagen buchstäblich eine Welt
macht auf einem Rollen fällt von A nach
B ja und haben im Grunde gar nicht ernst
genommen und für die war das dann
sozusagen eher eine Frage der
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen das heißt da sind
auf ganz vielen Ebenen ganz viele
verschiedene Dinge ich musste
zumindestens ein echtes Interesse also
ob man die Russen und mochte oder nicht
Mann war ja zwangsläufig mit ihnen
konfrontiert man hatte russisch in der
Schule genau die russische Kultur spielt
ja im Alltag der DDR Ebene Rolle es gab
Begriffe die man übernommen hat aus dem
aus dem Osten aus aus Russland und das
war jetzt kein irrsinnig fremder
Kulturkreis aus der Sicht der DDR Bürger
und das ist irgendwie so geblieben und
die die Deutungshoheit über die Russen
die ist komplett an den Westen
übergegangen also wenn die die Leute im
Osten werden da nicht nach ihrer Meinung
oder ihren Erfahrungen gefragt und wenn
du 40 Jahre in etwas gelebt hast falls
es ihm die 40 Jahre waren manchmal weiß
ich auch kürzer genau 40 Jahren etwas
gelernt dann ist das ein Teil deiner
Identität und mal völlig egal wie
kritisch du gegenüber den Russen gewesen
bist und welche Probleme du mit der
Parteiführung gehabt hast und so weiter
du lässt dir das wer du bist und was du
bist nicht von außen erklären das weißt
Du und das können die anderen gar nicht
so wie du das weißt wissen und diese wie
nennt sich das wenn man keinen Schmuck
von von
Native Americans mehr tragen darf
kulturelle an like ja genau
hier könnte man von kultureller
Übergriffigkeit sprechen ja also wir
haben den Osten den Osten erklärt so
jetzt könnten böse Zungen sagen das
macht ihr beiden ja auch schon wieder
aber wir könnten wir könnten doch
vielleicht mal ein Video Podcast zu dem
Thema machen mit jemand der im Osten
sozialpädagogisch darüber gern mal
sprechen vielleicht kriegen wir das mal
auf die Reihe aber
wir haben schon mal gesprochen über
ILCO kowalchuk Berliner Historiker sehr
interessanter Mann der mit die klügsten
Dinge gesagt hat finde ich in letzter
Zeit wenn es genau um dieses Thema ging
und er sagt dass dieses Bild sozusagen
dass die Ostdeutschen von den Russen
haben das ist viel uneindeutiger als wir
uns das gelegentlich so erzählen es ist
wahnsinnig ambivalent Russland als Feind
sagt er und gleichzeitig Russland als
Vorbild ja und dieser Zwiespalt hat sich
halt auch durch die komplette DDR
gezogen ja also auf der anderen Seite
hunderttausende Vergewaltigungen durch
sowjetische Soldaten nach dem in der
Ostzone aber dann auch die Begeisterung
für russische Kultur ja die Furcht vor
der russischen Armee ja und auf der
anderen Seite das Mitleid sozusagen mit
dieser sowjetischen Bevölkerung die in
der Masse viel
ärmer war als es der durchschnittliche
DDR-Bürger richtig sieht die DDR war das
im Vergleich wirtschaftlich
prosperierendste Land des sogenannten
Ostblocks richtig genau und und er sagt
interessant ist also diese Ambivalenz
die hört quasi auf so
Anfang der Nullerjahre fängt das so an
so eine merkwürdige komische
Einmütigkeit in der Bewertung dieser
deutsch-russischen Beziehungen er sagt
das war zu spüren das erste Mal 92 als
Putin damals in Dresden wenn es sich
vielleicht Semperopernball das und
Dankes Orden bekommen
täglich der der CDU Ministerpräsident
hat damals die Laudatio gehalten ich
weiß nur 2009 ne muss man sich auf der
Zunge zergehen lassen da war Belgien
schon passiert und da war auch schon
grossni in Schutt und Asche gelegt
worden von demselben Typen der dann
Dankesworten bekommen hat und das war ab
da kippte das so da wurde das plötzlich
so merkwürdig irgendwie verklärt und es
gab dann auch so so beschreibt ja noch
so T-Shirts zum Beispiel wo dann in
kyrillisch bestimmte Dinge drauf standen
zum Beispiel der Satz wenn du das lesen
kannst bist du kein dummer Wessi wer
hast oder vielen Dank dass ich so eine
Verbrüderung mit mit mit aber
wahrscheinlich von jüngeren genau
Ihren eigenen Kult gemacht haben und
Spaß an der Provokation hatten genau ja
kommen wir zur AFD zurück ja also wenn
wir das jetzt so zusammenfassen könnte
man ja die These Wagen die Tatsache dass
Deutschland nicht
Deutschland im deutsches möglichen Sinne
geworden ist ja sondern das ist ein Teil
des Westens geworden ist ist etwas was
vielen Menschen im Osten bis heute fremd
ist und dass sie sich vielleicht
wünschen es gäbe ein autonomeres
Deutschland also ein außenpolitisch
autonomer aus Deutschland ein
Deutschland das in aller erster Linie
auf deutsche Interessen guckt und jetzt
sozusagen nicht die Westbindung in den
Mittelpunkt stellt wie das im Augenblick
ja dann statt der Fall ist könnte auch
eine der Quellen sein aus denen sich die
AFD speist dass man sagt wir verkaufen
uns an die Amerikaner wir verzichten auf
dieses günstige russische Gas hier sind
auch bekloppt dass er das jetzt
irgendwie machen und so ne also das ist
jetzt ich meine Zapfen ja viele Quellen
an eine andere Quelle ist in der
corona-zeit natürlich gewesen dass man
den anderen unterstellt hat sie wollten
jeden starken Obrigkeitsstaat
ausgerechnet die AFD ja die Nazis in
ihren Reihen hat die von nichts anderem
Träumen als von einem brutalen Obrigkeit
also das ist natürlich voller paradox
die ganze Geschichte aber solange ich
dieses Schema
Konformismus nonnenkonformismus für
wichtiger erachte als rechts oder links
sondern sage das zentrale ist bin ich
angepasst plapper ich das nach was alle
sagen was die Medien verbreiten und so
weiter oder bin ich ein Freigeist ja
also Palio libertär wieder ja ein
Freigeist der sich da von denen keinen
Bären aufbinden lässt der selbstständig
denkt ja der eigenständig ist und der
sich nicht vereinnahmen lässt und die
beiden Zutaten ja dieser Nationalismus
auf der einen Seite und das Paleo
libertäre auf der anderen Seite die
haben beide rekrutieren die einen nicht
unerheblichen Pool und die die einen
fühlen sich in dem Einlager wohler und
die anderen fühlen sich in einem anderen
Lager oder aber eine Partei die regieren
würde könnte diesen Widerspruch nicht
aushalten
wenn sie tatsächlich Entscheidungen zum
Beispiel in in der Pandemie treffen muss
ja wo der eine Flügel den möglichst
starken Staat will der eine rigorose
Gesundheitspolitik macht und der andere
Flügel der Partei den man jetzt nicht
Flügeln denn also die andere Teil der
Partei sagt der stadthaltig raus meine
Gesundheit ist meine Sache das würde ja
in der Praxis sie nichts funktionieren
ja also Thema Migrationspolitik das
interessanten da sind wir wieder bei
Sonneberg der der neue Landrat jetzt der
AFD Landrat in Sonneberg der kann über
Migration oder auch
Asylbewerber die kommt kann der sagen
was er will die werden ihm zugewiesen
das hat er nicht in der Hand aber wie
die wie die Quartiere aussehen das ja
und ob er sowohl oder geldlichen Schulen
ja oder Container aber prinzipiell
kriegt er eine Ansage aus Berlin die da
lautet morgen kommen so und so viele
Menschen zu dir so läuft das überall in
Deutschland
und daraus speist sich auch zum Teil
auch bei bei Landräten wir reden häufig
in der Sendung mit Landräten ist total
interessant Tanja Schweiger zum Beispiel
aus Regensburg mit der amwer Vor einiger
Zeiten sehr interessantes Gespräch
darüber geführt das ist die Landrätin
von den Freien Wählern die in Regensburg
zum Beispiel dieses Schiff in ihrer Not
irgendwann angemietet hat weil sie
einfach keinen Platz mehr hatte und die
sagt schon mal wir sind einfach
hoffnungslos überfordert weil selbst
wenn ich es hinkriege erstmal ein Bett
und ein Dach über dem Kopf zu
organisieren dann komm er danach
unzählige andere Fragen nämlich wo gehen
die Kinder dieser Menschen hin auf
welche Kita von welchen Erziehern werden
sie erzogen von welchen Lehrern werden
sie später unterrichtet wo gibt es die
Wohnungen für all diese Menschen und so
weiter wir schaffen es ja auch nicht die
400.000 Wohnungen zu bauen die wir uns
gegenseitig versprochen haben weil wir
dann ja wieder die Facharbeiter dafür
gar nicht haben und so weiter das heißt
der hängt eine riesige Kette dran und
was die Leute dann vor Ort erleben in
Mecklenburg gab es die Geschichte dieses
kleinen Dorfes glaube ich 500 Leute
leben und plötzlich kommen
vier oder 500 Menschen aus aller Herren
Länder und die werden dann dort
kurzzeitig einfach runtergebracht mit
einem Vorlauf von teilweise drei vier
fünf Tagen
also wollen wir dann ernsthaft zur
Arroganz sein und sagen wer das müsst
ihr aber alles tolerieren ist ja wohl
selbstverständlich weil wir nicht seit
die böse Rassisten sorry es tut mir leid
ich ich komme da nicht mit das ist etwas
das kann logistisch nicht funktionieren
und es ist keine Frage
für eine
nicht moralgedrängte ja Migration also
muss nicht die ganze Zeit immer um Gut
und Böse oder um Superlative geht also
entweder Humanist oder Nazi so genau
danke ja sondern es geht um viel viel
mehr Pragmatismus was können wir leisten
und es geht ja auch darum also ich habe
wenn du mit mit Meinungsforschern
sprichst z.B ist schon interessanter
Punkt und den darf man deswegen auch
nicht weglassen die sagen die
entscheidende Träger für die AFD ist
nicht Ukraine Krieg ist nicht die
Inflation ist nicht das Thema Wirtschaft
ist nicht das Thema Heizung
sondern der entscheidende Träger ist und
deswegen wenn man genau hinguckt sieht
man auch der Aufstieg jetzt dieser
neuerliche Aufstieg der AFD der hat
schon letzten Sommer bekommen das ist
genau das Thema Migration eigentlich
fast ausschließlich das ist das Thema
und das geht also was was mich natürlich
bei der Frage beschäftigt ist wir haben
ja über Migration schon mehrfach
gesprochen genau das allergrößte Problem
was ich in der Migrationspolitik sehe
ist dass wir das worauf wir uns alle
einigen können egal welcher Partei wir
Angehörigen wir wählen dass man die
Fluchtursachen bekämpfen muss dass das
nicht angegangen worden ist das
funktioniert auch so kurzfristig nicht
nee ja was heißt zu kurzfristig
migrationskrise 2015 seitdem acht Jahre
vergangen und seitdem fast nichts
passiert also wir machen eine absolute
Defensive Migrationspolitik wir
verteidigen unsere Grenzen wir versuchen
besser abzufangen höhere Zäune bessere
Patrouillen mehr und so weiter ja wir
denken uns härtere Kriterien an wir rein
darf und wenn die aus wir rein davon
will nicht rein darf und so weiter aber
damit hält man das Problem ja dauerhaft
nicht auf ja das ist ja versuchen mit
der Luftpumpe die Windrichtung zu ändern
was man machen müsste wäre natürlich
viel viel mehr in Afrika und jetzt
müsste ja die AFD wenn Sie clever wäre
eine afrika-strategie vorlegen also mal
zu erklären wie das denn aussehen soll
dass wir guten Gewissens kaum noch
jemand aufnehmen müssen außer er kommt
jetzt aus dem Bürgerkriegsland ganz
unmittelbar aber wir müssen ganz viele
Menschen die vor dem Hungertod fliegen
nicht mehr zurückschicken weil wir ganz
ganz viel getan haben dafür dass
Menschen in Afrika heute noch verhungern
da kommt eben nichts aber aber da kommt
eben auch nichts von den etablierten
Parteien und so lange von den
etablierten Parteien nicht was
konstruktiveres kommt als das was wir
bisher machen braucht die AFD auch keine
Lösung vorzulegen ja ist richtig das ist
übrigens letzter Punkt Richard das ist
übrigens das was mich mittlerweile fast
noch mehr frustriert und zum Teil auch
auch sauer macht wie zum Beispiel an der
eine eine
bürgerliche Partei wie die CDU zum
Beispiel darauf reagiert mir das jetzt
angesehen dann dann dann treten dort
Leute wie Claudia Pechstein auf und und
tun so als hätte dieses Land kein
anderes Thema als die Frage wo ist bitte
zum nächsten Zigeunerschnitzel geht und
das ist ja so furchtbar ist dass wir gar
nicht mehr Zigeunerschnitzel sagen
dürfen und tut so als hätten wir alle
gemeinsam eine schwere Zigeunerschnitzel
Fixierung das ist ihre ja was will man
denn damit erreichen dürfen stimmlich
der Trittbrettfahrerei du vertreibst
Gespenster die außer ihr keiner sieht in
dem Moment kein Mensch leidet darunter
das meint das Ding Zigeunerschnitzel
heißt oder nicht übrigens war ich
letztens tatsächlich in der Pommesbude
wo tatsächlich noch Zigeunerschnitzel
stand und auch Zigeunersoße also
offensichtlich gibt es da nicht jemand
der dann den Laden zu macht oder
irgendwie sowas ja also offensichtlich
ist es sogar noch erlaubt ist vielleicht
unterschiedlich aber offensichtlich noch
erlaubt na jetzt im Ernst das ist
unwichtigste Frage von der Welt ja und
damit zu punkten ist ja nichts anderes
als ein billiger Versuch ein paar AFD
wieder zurückzuholen und ich meine so
doof sind die jetzt nicht alle auf
ganzer Linie ja dass sie deswegen eine
andere Partei als sie AFD wählen weil
die CDU in den Gesang damit einstimmt
jedenfalls einiges die du Leute ich
finde das merkwürdig ja auch dieses
ganze Thema ganz ehrlich wenn Regen im
Alltag wen betreffen im Alltag Menschen
die Gendern ist das wirklich ein Thema
aber dass man zu Hause spricht ist dass
das Thema dass die Leute zu Hause
wirklich bewegt wenn wenn Menschen
sprechen und dabei klingen als hätten
sie Schluckauf das ist deren
persönliches Thema sind wir nicht
tolerant genug das einfach mal
auszuhalten ja ist es schön nein also
man könnte daran schoßen wenn man einer
Universität arbeitet dann kann das einem
schon passieren dass man dann irgendwie
so angeflaumt und irgendwas wird oder so
aber ich glaube die allermeisten Leute
die sich darüber aufregen kommen selten
mit Leuten zusammen die ideologisch auf
Schändern waren
von ihnen weg ist ja ja auch auch die
die Frage nach irgendwelchen komischen
Toilettenhäuschen und so weiter da wird
dann sozusagen das ist wie das Krokodil
im Stadtteich dass jeden Sommer
verlässlich irgendwo auftaucht aber halt
leider noch nie gesehen wurde genau der
kann man Chemie das Ungeheuer von Loch
neu ist
sich daran erinnert
ein 70 cm langer Brillen kein Mann
vorgestellt gehört ich habe ich habe ich
habe gelesen Log Ness in Schottland in
diesem Sommer kann es wirklich passieren
das trocknet geradeaus ist völlig irre
und dann finden wir dann finden wir das
Skelett von Nessi so s SS es wird
weniger das Wasser ähnlich ich stand da
mal was du Gemeinschaft nee das ist
wahnsinnig schöne Landschaft da ich lieg
da diese diese diese diese diese Moore
da diese hoch es ist traumhaft schön und
im Herbst dann schneit es dann auch so
ein bisschen oder im Winter auch ganz
oder schneese das ist ganz bezaubern
wenn man sich diese arme Kreatur
vorstellt die da alleine sind ja
Millionen Ausfahrt ja und vom warmen
Jura mehr Träume aus dem ursprünglich
mal gekommen ist
aber jetzt in diesem Sommer es könnte ja
sein dass sie dann so in kältester liegt
und deswegen Millionen von Jahren alt
wird sich im Schlamm eingegraben genau
maximal würde jetzt gefunden
energieeffizient genau
das ist natürlich für den Tourismus in
Loch Ness das gestochen es ist super die
Chance das ist jetzt endlich mal
sichtbar wird also alle kommen und
gucken sich an wie die letzten fünf
Meter Wasser verschwinden und jeder
guckt wo was rausguckt und macht ein
Foto genau aber das meine ich weiß dass
manchmal frage ich mich also wie empören
uns dann noch mal ganz kurzer Gedanke zu
AFD und und dann regen sich alle auf
aber dann frage ich manchmal ist das
wirklich unsere ernsthafte
Auseinandersetzung damit dass wir dann
Zigeunerschnitzel sagen nein das ist
alles Mist die ernsthafte
Auseinandersetzung besteht darin die AFD
nach ihren Lösungsvorschlägen zu fragen
so ich hatte vor einiger Zeit ein
Gespräch mit Frauke Petri weil ja weil
mich die Frau schon interessiert hat
weil man konnte über sie viele sagen
aber mit Sicherheit nicht dass sie dumm
ist und mir ist in den ganzen
Fernsehdiskussionen indem sie eingeladen
war immer aufgefallen dass man sie immer
so mit nazi-sprüchen von irgendwelchen
Kollegen die sie selber nicht gemacht
hat Partei Kollegen und sowas fundiert
dann sieht man die Defensive getrieben
hat und das stand immer unter dem Thema
Nazi oder nicht Nazi und was ich nie
erfahren habe von Frauke Petry war zu
wissen worauf will die AFD eigentlich
hinaus wie sieht ein gutes Deutschland
aus und da habe ich sie gefragt ob sie
in der Lage wäre mir positive Visionen
für Deutschland zu nennen ja oder
auszumalen unter einer Bedingung es darf
das Wort nicht nicht vorkommen und das
konnte sie nicht sie kamen nicht aus dem
nicht raus also wir wollen jedenfalls
nicht ja das in den Schulen geändert
wird wir wollen jedenfalls nicht ja das
immer mehr Ausländer uns hier kulturell
über fremden wir wollen jedenfalls nicht
und nicht nicht und nicht und ich würde
von der AFD so gerne wissen dass nicht
interessiert mich nicht das kenne ich na
ja wie immer man zum einzelnen nicht
steht sondern mich interessiert wie mir
wie sieht eine konstruktive Klimapolitik
aus der AFD du hattest ja die letzten
Tage großen Klimaexperten AFD zu Gast
was würde die Idee im Ukraine Krieg
tatsächlich morgen tun wenn Sie die
Regierungsmehrheit hätte also was ganz
konkret also dass man eine Vorstellung
davon kriegt ihr immer sagen soll wo
sollte wo soll Deutschland hin raus aus
der NATO tatsächlich ein eigenständiges
Deutschland also als eigener Blog in
dieser Welt wie soll das funktionieren
wie sieht eine Renationalisierung der
Wirtschaft aus wenn man sich überlegt
dass alle Wirtschaftsverträge alle ganz
wichtigen grundsätzlichen Abkommen ja
alle in Brüssel getroffen worden sind
und europäisch festgelegt
Wettbewerbsrecht und und und und und und
und also wie sollte eine die
Europäisierung in der Praxis aussehen
würde das nicht unausgesetzten
Rechtsbruch zum Beispiel
sollten noch Öl aussah die Arabien
kaufen von von Muslimen die die AFD ja
sogar nicht mag sollten zum Beispiel ja
genau und einfach einfach mal ich will
was ich am liebsten noch mehr hätte als
das praktische ist so ein Bild also dass
mir jemand von der AFD mal so
vorschwärmt ja wie ein Deutschland nach
10 Jahren AF Landesregierung aussieht
ich stelle mir vor dass sie so aus wie
früher in der rama-reklame weißt du du
hast dann so blau-weiß karierte
Tischdecken oder rot-weiß karierte ja
und dann hast du so sonnige blonde
Menschen die sitzen um bei Sonnenschein
im Garten um so ein Frühstückstisch rum
wo nur deutsche Produkte drauf stehen
und irgendwie sowas also ich weiß es
nicht also das klingt jetzt vielleicht
zynisch ich meine es gar nicht zynisch
ich habe keine Vorstellung davon es gibt
ja in der Geschichte der Menschheit kein
freiwilliges zurück wir können das was
da zum Teil in Brandenburg noch erhalten
geblieben ist das können wir ja nicht
mehr zur Blaupause eines künftigen
Deutschlands machen also wie soll in
einer in einer globalisierten Welt unter
den heutigen Bedingungen dieses Mehr an
Deutschland denn praktisch realisierbar
sein oder aussehen und das sind Fragen
die mich wirklich interessieren und ich
würde mich gar nicht streiten wollen ja
ich würde gerne einfach mal zwei Stunden
zuhören ein AFD Vortrag in dem das Wort
nicht vorkommt um überhaupt meine
Vorstellung davon zu haben was die
Vorstellungen dieser Menschen vom Guten
sind sichert es wird nicht passieren
vermutlich wird es nicht passieren nein
es wird nicht passieren und
ich glaube trotzdem wir müssen uns wir
dürfen uns einfach diese intellektuelle
Faulheit nicht leisten und uns nicht mit
mit allen die in den Parlamenten sitzen
einfach schlichte und ergreifend
auseinanderzusetzen nicht so sicher sein
dass wir immer und in allem die Guten
sind genau ja das nervt mich ja also wir
sind die guten und jetzt kommen diese
ganzen Idioten die alle die AFD wählen
und dann müssen wir irgendwann jetzt
schon ein Fünftel und irgendwann ein
Drittel der deutschen Bevölkerung für
politisch nicht unzurechnungsfähig
erklären um uns selbst noch weiterhin
für die guten alten zu können und in
diese Situation dürfen wir nicht kommen
das heißt also mehr darüber nachdenken
welche Probleme wir alle nicht lösen aus
denen sich die AFD weiß ja ist
mindestens so wichtig wie sich
rhetorisch davon abzuwehren
in diesem Sinne Richert spannend dank
sehr ich danke dir habe einen guten Tag
Markus tschüss
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pots
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]